Các bạn có định và tặng qua đồng chỉ buổi thế dưới,
tụi bếng phạm miếng chính cho rằng Việt nặng nhật nước tinh bường,
rao đồng chỉ phạm thế dưới chọn sách dưới trước giám đốc tại học Tức ra Hanoi.
Đây là một đồng viết dữ lớn,
có ở ước cầu chắc giận lối với đại học Cuc ra Hanoi trong gia đận mới.
Tụi bếng đánh ra cao nên tặng học thuật xuất sắc và bây giờ kinh nghiệm của tân giám đốc đại học Cuc ra Hanoi.
Thưa quái chiến học tập đến các vị trí lãnh đạo,
khoảng lý trong lĩnh vừa qua của vật không gẻ.
Trong thế gián tới, thu tưởng chỉ đạo đại học Cuc ra Hanoi,
tập chung và những vụ trong tâm,
theo đó sẽ dựng khu rô thi đại học Cuc ra theo mô hình 5 trong 1.
Ló là trở thành chung tâm đạo tại năng,
chung tâm nghiên cứu chuyển ra công nghệ,
chung tâm đổi mởi sáng tạo tâm cửc ra và cú tế,
chung tâm đô thi đại học thông mên, giảnh đại,
chung tâm thử nghiệm hợp tắc công tư và đạo tạo nghiên cứu.
Tụi bếng cũng đệ nghị đại học Cuc ra Hanoi tăng cường kích nối bà nhà,
gồm nhà nước nhà chường, vân nghiệp để đưa đại học Cuc ra Hanoi của người tâm cú vật.
Thủ đứng khẳng đệnh chính vụ sẽ luôn đồng hành
bỗ trợ đại học Cuc ra Hanoi thực hiện sự mạnh nào tạo
của những lực trước lượng cao và hoặc định chính xác chờ đất nước.
Đầu thời bây giờ tỏ tinh tưởng và tinh thần gần kết của đường mũ cán bộ
rằng viên đại học Cuc ra Hanoi với sự dẫn giác của lãnh gạo mới,
sẽ tích tục tả hãi như thành công.
Phát biểu nhận dự vụ, đông chỉ vui thế duy bây giờ tỏ luôn luôn
và phát biểu chuyện hống đoàn kết, chỉ tỏe sẽ dự vụ tập thể lãnh gạo đoàn kết thống nhất,
khơi dễ khác vọng công viến của đổi mũ chỉ thức tinh qua lãnh gân chủ sử mình bài làm nền tàn trong hãn đổ phần chi
nhận trọng chẳng mới, đồng chỉ vui thế duy câm kết sẽ đem hết năng lực,
tâm viết và kinh giệm tích lủy được, nỗ lực cao nhất phát biểu chắc nghiệp,
giữa vững bản lĩnh, vương mẫu trong công tác,
cùng tập thể lãnh đạo và tăng thể cắn bộ rằng viên đoàn kết,
nội mới, hành động quyết liệt hiểu qua, đưa đây học quốc gia hãn hội phát triển sức đáng
với nền bình và ký vọng của đàn của năng, của nền nốt của chính phủ và thủ tương chính phủ.
Để đóng góc tích thức và sự nghiệp xây dự và mỏ vệ tụ quốc.